so a few weeks back when we did our
Apple watch Ultra First Impressions we
mentioned that we were going to have a
triathlete actually take it through its
Paces I have Lucas Neo here who is a
triathlete an Iron Man and you have
taken over 500 kilometers in totality
from running swimming cycling you've
never used an Apple Watch before no
you're not paid responsive for this
video no you've never used an iPhone no
first time walk us through your
experience with the Apple watch Ultra
the pros and the cons before Ultra I'm
using Garmin 955 all right now okay yeah
okay that is um for everything okay so
use the Garment which I understand I use
Garmin before it's not the most
user-friendly interface right yeah
there's a lot of metrics a lot of
information but not always easiest to
get a hold of yeah so what was it when
you first got to the ultra what was your
first initial Impressions on it of
course it's easy to use right you don't
need the Retro instruction manual to use
it and it's like a phone yeah right it
gives you a feeling this is a phone on
on a wrist that's always been the ethos
of the Apple watches for the most part
but now we get to the ultra this is
designed for people like you who go to
the extremes through workouts through
running and cycling and swimming and
hiking and all that stuff what were some
of the key things that you were looking
for that this watch would do for you
first is definitely the battery life it
has to last The Matrix in the cycling in
the running and the streaming it's
sufficient for basic news right there
are some missing Matrix that I would
love to have right but I've got it
settled through purchasing a third party
app what was they are called the app is
called work Outdoors okay right there is
like 650 Matrix for you to select wow so
you can put whatever you want on the
screen if you see right now yeah I have
the maps on and the pacing just within
the map fantastic so it's up it's
utilizing what's inside the ultra but
also using it with its own interface
yeah okay all right so let me talk to
you a little bit about running first and
foremost because with running what were
some of the things that you liked about
the watch and some things that you wish
were improved I like it that they have
some Advanced Matrix such as GCT long
contact time yeah right that's the swipe
length right the measurement of cadence
yeah in Garmin I think we have to do the
chest strike in order to measure this
right now in terms of cycling we did
talk about this because obviously when
we use you know we have our Garmin
computers on it we have our power meters
we have everything that syncs up
anti-plus Bluetooth unfortunately the
Apple watch Ultra doesn't do this at
this time right yes what is lacking is
is definitely the the sink with the N
plus yeah yeah that one if it has then
I'll probably get one myself okay now
wow the rain's going to come soon
weather's changing really fast okay so
let's talk a little bit about swimming
yeah how is this for swimming for
swimming uh it has the Auto lab feature
yeah
um but it's really a bit more difficult
to configure yeah on the ultra when in
the Stream okay because uh this the
buttons is limited so that is one thing
that we can't get used to yeah and also
the intervals we can't do it like how we
do it on our garment why what's the
difference the difference is sometimes
when we stream we don't want it to be
Auto lab when pressed and then go I
should yeah so that is one issue as well
okay now let's talk a little bit about
hiking because you've obviously been
hiking with it what do you like about
this and what what are some things
missing you know Apple appetized that
you know you can go on a desert yeah
right extreme
I don't think so because the battery
life would one of the main concern right
yeah and you have to bring your phone
with you I mean you can't get an e Sim
you can connect it by esim to have
Cellular Connection through the watch
yeah on itself so you can do that now
Apple's touting 36 hours in battery life
obviously depending on how you use it
what's been your battery life usage I'm
a bit uh skeptical of 36 hours okay we
talk about 18 hours it's possible
definitely you can get to a marathon
okay Lucas here's a quick question for
you yeah would you buy the Apple watch
Ultra honestly honestly honestly uh for
me it's a no okay right because I use my
Garmin as Fitness device right but apple
is a better Smart Watch okay fair enough
I mean this is the first gen uh that
they're you know this kind of watch
they're doing so yeah to be fair to
Apple there's a lot of things that
they're learning from people like
yourself and other athletes that are out
there taking through his Paces so
obviously I think with the Gen 2 or
maybe some firmware updates we maybe see
a lot of improvements but but no this is
a fair assessment and this is something
that other people have said as well is
that as a fitness watch it is lacking
some things yeah it has a lot but it's
lacking some things okay Lucas it's
starting to rain right now yeah
let's uh let's just walk a little
handheld with me come with me all right
okay all right so we're just getting
some shade real quick here before the
rain really comes down but just to wrap
up this video so in essence who would
you recommend this watch for pretty much
um everyone that uh it's not so serious
like me so more like casual Fitness a
little bit more you could probably go a
little bit beyond just casual Fitness
people but for the hardcore athletes
yeah they're gonna push it to the
extreme not quite there yet right yeah
because it doesn't sing with the ants
plus right right yeah which a lot of
people rely on for different devices for
power meters for Cadence especially for
cycling and things like that now it
can't seem to a heart rate monitor I
know that but outside of that it's very
limited obviously it's the first gen
device from Apple so we have to give
them credit for that that they're going
to learn through this and they're gonna
obviously adapt things and fix things as
they go in terms of the apps available
did you get the chance to look at some
of the apps to see what we're besides
that one I haven't done much research
yet so maybe with more time uh there'll
be apps that solve the issues that I
have right the good news uh for apple is
uh you you do need a new watch you just
need a new app right right it can be
soft too apps sure sure it's a good
point all right Lucas well with that
let's uh get out of the rain obviously
the watch can handle it but we can't um
thank you so much for trying this watch
for the last couple weeks all right and
uh yeah with that take care man all the
best on your upcoming Iron Mans thank
you thank you and thanks for trying to
watch for us and if you like this video
let us know in the comment section below
any questions you have for Lucas we'll
get those answered for you and if you
like this review check out more of our
videos right here